estambul se ha levantado este martes
bajo una capa de nieve que ha colapsado
el centro de la ciudad y no ha permitido
que los coches privados puedan salir a
las calles hasta este mismo mediodía así
lo ha firmado la gobernación de estambul
que ha pedido a los ciudadanos que no
salgan de sus casas a menos que sea
estrictamente necesario también a los
niños que estos días están de vacaciones
estambul ha recibido así varios
centímetros de nieve pero muchos menos
que en las afueras de la ciudad sobre
todo en el aeropuerto donde andan en
algunos casos se ha llegado a 80
centímetros de nieve que ha forzado al
aeropuerto de estambul el mayor de
europa y que fue estrenada hace tan solo
un par de años a completamente cerrar
hasta nuevo aviso se espera dicen las
autoridades del aeropuerto que pueda
reabrir esta misma madrugada pero podría
ser que siguiese más horas cerrado a
causa de que la nieve continuará cayendo
sobre la gran ciudad de turquía y no se
espera que pare hasta probablemente el
jueves de hecho la nieve ha causado el
colapso de una de las terminales de
cargo del aeropuerto de estambul no ha
causado ni heridos ni muertos pero las
imágenes muestran como completamente el
techo se derruyó bajo el hangar donde
podrían haber habido aviones de momento
la ciudad
bajo las tareas de mantenimiento para
poder adaptar la ciudad una de las
ciudades que más nieva del sur de europa
para que los ciudadanos puedan volver a
una vida normal que ha sido truncada
estás este finales de enero